citizens of the reject Nation we are about to
watch the animated version of one of my favorite
Batman comics Batman hush so please do hit that
notification Bell hit that subscribe button hit
that comment bar leave a little comment what's
uh one of your favorite Batman comics do you
like hush because I like hush quite a bit and of
course leave a like as well while you're pressing
all those buttons but Greg did tell me he prefaced
this different in the comic very curious how this
differs what's going on how are you the comic I
checked it out of the library a bunch of times I
probably read a couple pages and never finished it
so this is going to be great I am very intrigued
by how those pages relate whether or not you
remember those pages at all judgmental about those
specifications six pages I enjoyed of Jim Leon
years ago very different we're about to find out
so please do check that out as well as checking
out a brand new Batman shirt the bad verse we're
tying things together in averse of bats we got
all the Batmans in honor of both Batman hush and
the Flash because they're some Batman in there
as well and as ever if you would like to watch
this in its entirety if you want to see us hush
then become a patron that's the only place you're
gonna see us quiet frankly you want those moments
of Silence those moments of reverence be a patron
front to back start to finish full Journey
but without further Ado it's time to hush
[Music]
we're not driving what's happening whoa I'm
confused don't don't get too creative damn I
don't know if I trust it it is acceptable to take
one night off speak to someone about sports yeah
Selena Kyle is here perhaps Miss Kyle is
definitely Alfred come on for at least
a year 16 months come on it's cap
always at the light let's go they're on
a group call found out the shipment was
tonight so thought I'd torch it yes I weighs
it on fire how you been Selena you could say
I'm at a Crossroads I used to love my work
at the gallery this is Thomas Elliott good
friend and world renowned brain surgeon
and I wouldn't say world renowned maybe
the US and parts of Canada that's the world
all right Bane has abducted a child this
needs my attention but it was good seeing
you I'd like to catch up yeah you would
mysterious unknown number that glimmer in her eyes
eight-year-old Edward Dupree has been kidnapped by
the criminal known as Bane he has demanded an
undisclosed Ransom ah news 52 miles yeah it's
a whole reboot of the news brand new universe of
news we have your money don't hurt the boy you me
and Dupree's money just love the idea that Bane
watches the news yes I love this commercial the
lying Legacy Media I must take to True social
the anger changed his hair her Venom social
everything will be
fun [Laughter]
my Venom is stronger I am stronger stupid or bad
[Music]
ah in the face must be extremely
painful for him for him
to be a side effect of the new Venom which
means his mind is under the same strength
oh you're a junkie Venom I mean Bane you're a
Venom junkie Bane it's a lot of words go together
get it
good shot
get him Harry did good
oh Ivy the League of Assassins has no business
here the league has been in flux and in the
chaos the life-giving power of a Lazarus
Pit was exploited by an unknown Intruder
yes if you know anything of this matter no
but I'll look into it next time call First
wait where's the ransom ah she take it
come on world's greatest detective oh
I was about to say I thought it was
Catwoman following him personally
disappointed yeah it's a good mislead with
uh Shiva yeah Catwoman turkey long enough
they have the professional
respect that when they're in
you know their suits yeah who knows
who might be listening on rooftops
Catwoman knows the train schedules
and now
oh oh wow
they just decapitated one of Disneyland
oh hush Batman they're doing a cold rap
grabbing some of the imagery and like the
impact from the Jim Lee art yeah and like
making it work but I I do see a couple
little tweaks already it's interesting
theme music too yeah it was really unnerving
violin told you it was him fell out of the sky
like a dead pigeon what the hell there's
only one way to deal with this freak
and then ate that one there's a
three strikes law in this state boys
foreign [Music] you know some
guys pay for that I was about
to say you better hope he's not into that
hey yeah all right
dang dang get away from him you're working with
Bane and you're going down come quietly
and you won't get hurt Ah that's adorable
but is it a cat fight or a bat
fight take care of your boss
he's not my boss we are colleagues what
happened they couldn't keep up don't
worry yourself with anyone or anything
except pleasing me yes mistress is that
Lake Bell oh maybe I think it is I
wonder if she was this before early
oh that's the guy glimmer you can go now ah
okay damn it I was just about to ship them
but Harley hey that's true that's true and bats
they're so cute and bats what the [__] [Music]
50 50. maybe I'll finish our deal another way oh
if my vitals don't remain well vital I have a
job that will pay 10 times what you made today
think of all the fertilizer you could buy his head
injury is beyond me I'm afraid he needs a hospital
Batman can go to the hospital but Reckless Playboy
Bruce Wayne can absolutely Dick Grayson will take
him to the emergency room 45 miles an hour
should be adequate remember to tuck and roll
pretty screwed up you guys have a plan for this
I got an encyclopedia yeah this situation this
had trauma surgery couldn't have gone better hey
but you don't have to stay out of the fast lane
for a while I owe you so much it's the least
I can do for all the time to left you hanging
oh wait I haven't been a very good friend you
kidding me look at all the publicity you gave
me hey I searched for searching friend I need to
go to Black gate prison my dad suggest this one
oh a headpiece has a bit more padding
it's the bat concussion suit battle
for the world's greatest vegetable sir hahaha
I love a Batman vegetable costume I love
the use of bottles I always forget that's
what Butler's you know piece of there but
bottle I need to speak with Bane I believe
he's working with Poison Ivy and Catwoman
I need to know why five minutes is all no
what's going on didn't you sedate him yes ma'am
enough to drink a herd of elephants oh they
wanted him to get arrested Ivy was controlling
me she made me steal your money first verse
that woman down
and a Little Help from Spider-Man
that is a strong drone yeah
hahaha
pin cushioned him his trunks to the
face you're going after Ivy and I
want in I have a code Revenge isn't
part of it how about the address of
our pheromone controlled minions give me the
information and I'll take care of Ivy nope
fine we work together on this what's the
address oh I'm not done with my demands
yes we've done this dance for so long
why don't you just the least bit curious
[Music] oh the back kiss
back curiosity killed the bat
oh yeah good shot right through the shattered
glass capes of billowing Avis and Metropolis
oh get the jet ready very pack the jewelry
I want to look pretty while I do this I
need my rings on how come you're still
hanging around don't you have an interview he's
coming here quite the get whoo that would be me
turtleneck yeah the turtleneck something tells me
a man like you is here for more than
an interview I do like to multitask
don't tell me you and the boy
scout have switched cities [Music]
Lex Corp makes a fortified ethylene compound
engineered to allow exotic plants to withstand
changes in locale I need the delivery
list of that compound for the last week
and you couldn't visit the person who does the
deliveries and is probably awake as we speak
information was deleted on her computer I assume
yours has a few more safeguards one or two
and my own screensaver my name on it
thrifted building I saved all your asses against
Cyborg Superman and I'll remind you I'm a Justice
League member now yes you are I just realized
this was that Cannon yeah because the rain
Wilson boys I was like I think I love his Lex
Luthor oh it's so fun I've come back to you no
one can resist you that's so true kitty but no
one fakes it with me okay crazy plant [__]
all right
cpb nose filters
[Music] I get close why don't you is
Batman your new boy toy it's always been
I have one too oh yeah
kill them oh don't do his Subs you just came
back fight this according to this continuity
damn
[Music]
that Batman always so prepared I mean make fun
of the bat utility belt all you want but he's got
everything you will ever need Gizmo's at the ready
back shirt repellent they're going in the water
I don't get my money if
they're still alive I won't
are you trying to resist oh seems my
kryptonite kisses need a touch-up damn
find them kill them yes God that green streak
that was cool yeah he's still looking at
her like they'll buy us some time but this is
Superman and if he wanted we'd be dead already
oh deep down he's a good person and deep
down I'm not oh oh Bruce Kryptonite brass
knuckles I've opened the gas mate one spark
from your heat vision you blow up the entire
block and you know what building we're under
[Music] made you look moment of distraction
the gas main I lied whoa [Music] oh
that's better of a good contingency plan
get control you can save her it's
your choice not Ivy's wow that
blackmail damn it okay looks like
we do it the hard way oh no [Music]
imagery
he made me do it double date there's a
great comic that's Batman double dating
with super van Lois and Catwoman it's so
good two issues and it's some of the best
I'm buying it's second we're done actually
two of my favorite issues at DC ever hit
synthetic Kryptonite you know
who made it working on it
[__] they keep not even bothering to like cut
her off with something yeah they're just almost
sweaters it's the Walmart of Poison Ivy's
just [Music] consider it oh not the hair
name now hush it's true he calls himself
hush I think your business here is done
I'm going to slowly float this way
get out of my city as I hover away
weren't supposed to throw Lois off the roof ugh
Superman was going to he's still covered for her
so I improvised that's what Partners do right
oh the little cat head bow oh yes yes Batman
find happiness pennyworth tells me you're
romantically involved with a Criminal now
it's only a date there are no ex criminals
father only ones who aren't breaking the law
at the moment how long did you take to line this
Frame Up it's pretty poised for any mission of
ours is a lonely endeavor if this trala provides
some carnal release so be it oh however I must
insist that you use protection and another thing
to cover your drink yes cover your drink Batman
don't get roofied man oh my God that's my favorite
birds of the Beast talk I don't know [Music]
oh he's not coming how are you and what do
you know about my pudding I know he needs
your help oh what you know I had a bet with
Eartha here that you wouldn't show up Earth
the KitKat lemon juice I've just been feeling the
need to change some things I've done some changing
myself since we first met thought maybe that's
why you dropped me I like that about you I hope
you're not entirely tamed but I'd like to balance
things more sure good for you too get after it
break out that Chris Christian Gray contract
oh yes yes they do it's a safe words Martha
what'd you say the name I mean hers is Clark oh
how much he'd love to watch an Italian Cloud
but I do like it's mirroring The Dark Knight
mass that mirrors the original uh Batman 66
mask sure that's clever it's a reference and a
reference the turducken of clownery along with the
Opera robbing you for a thousand box of tickets
I'm also here for my puddin who's been clown
napped oh there you are Bruce Wayne nice tax
hope it's not a rental oh you never get your
deposit back get the ladies to safety okay
but I'm coming back what are you gonna
do I'll be a hero Tom rabbit [Applause]
what is the caliber on that thing strong
very strong I thought it was a flare gun
but it's just a giant bullet like a
Mario Super Mario balencias laughs
dang
[Music] [Applause] no what
is it the theater folks say
oh she had a little blood stash back
there you've been hurt not that bad
bad smirk [Laughter] oh no oh geez is
that Thomas on the ground yeah Joker you
know what the joke is I'm totally innocent
well that doesn't even sound right does it
does not I was in a basement until five minutes
ago I'm also looking for Harley have you seen
Revenge bats
it's not fun if it's not me
I want you to break your code but for something
I actually did yeah Gotham needs Batman
oh
Man Hands of Fury and rage
tangents veg with Justice
well back to the Grind who's Robin these
days ouch well it's not Jason Todd store your
Treasures in Heaven where moths and rust cannot
destroy and thieves do not break in and steal
it's a real scripture where'd a good
moths then go there's no mods in heaven
judgment when your eye is healthy
your whole body is filled with light but when your
eye is unhealthy Proud Family and if the light you
think you have is actually Darkness how deep that
darkness is sermon especially for you bat sermon
it was all planned so Joker would wake up in time
to free himself arriving just as Tom was killed
the events of the past months reach as high as
Superman and as low as the Joker the full spectrum
but why kill Thomas Elliot he's got no connection
to Batman did have one with Bruce Wayne hush knows
Bruce Wayne is Batman oh boy let's not wait
another 10 years before seeing each other okay
there's just some business I need to take care
of first if I were you I wouldn't wait too long I
hey I was seeing someone on and off before
you called ah a mystery man what may the best
mystery man win be careful what you wish
for stay safe Bruce I wish for all of it
[Laughter]
this truck's defying physics yes Riddler that's
c-lister it's like they're all crawling out from
under the carpets now Riddler is is like
B to eight here no he's leveled up since
hush he's iconic I want you to know him for this
thing you and Selena Bruce Lena Bruce Lee that
mutton shop Riddler oh I just walked
in front of that one guy firing
trust that guy's not gonna clip him
[Applause] oh
yeah a battering ram bat pun
no where is he I know not whom you speak
of hush put you up to this can you rephrase
that in the form of a riddle this has got to be
exhausting dealing with you can't even imagine
you know shake things up shake shake shake
oh
make it over there just just watching
who are you I'm the man that will
destroy your life before taking it
oh
[Applause]
soon Batman very soon
that mean you always do that mirror trick you
know better yeah you're the mirror guy he won
the the one Hall too frankly those are changing
rooms you just got mad at Express [Laughter]
grab some of those discounts on the way out
that's true I want you to leave town I don't
have but you don't get to tell me what to do hush
told me he's going to hurt the ones closest to me
the ones I care for most oh I suffered a loss
it's been suggested that I'm handling it better
because I have you in my life in your life isn't
that a bit much maybe it's time to find out
are you sure I am then let me oh Bruce
Bruce Wayne is Batman
I can think of a few things
not getting out of town any faster oh
no no no no go up in the bat in the cat
I hate waiting but that scrapes
I had to upgrade my kevlar Body Armor
after that uh sorry nah you make me better
that was why you broke it that's when you
found out I was capable maniac [Applause]
stopping and if you can't control your
actions you're not quite sane and I was wrong
wrong oh thank you
that's what Nightwing thousand is
free time 200 300 500 a thousand the
Liberty to prepare tea with the Salted
biscuits so everyone knows who I am
there's Damian Robin his son [Laughter]
I love his displeased grunts if they can
land Brave in the Bold to be this tone
yeah fun but still dark and like family and
Bruce's both things yeah dude hey penguin
Harvey
[Music]
and these guys and henchmen hold on the henchmen
no
oh poor Alfred The Cry of freeze
oh my bad sauna what is that yeah
what what is that tube I don't know
look at this I'll even pay foreign
Bruce I'm asking you to spend
some time away from this with me
two minutes ago a silent alarm
was tripped at a medical practice
the office belongs to that doctor hush
killed at the Opera Thomas Elliott oh
maybe this is something the Batman needs
to do alone this shouldn't take long
extreme vacations they can do the
mission impossible to climb that's
the only way Bruce getting out of town
it's extreme vacation yeah glioblastoma
multiform brain tumor nearly inoperable
you up for a trip to Arkham oh joy oh joy
yeah he's not gone anywhere
suspect believed to be inside the ground
maybe the two coolest Side
characters teaming up yes
I forgot how much really like shifted
the tone of Batman books like the reveal
of Bruce Wayne the Catwoman like all
that I've been here before so have you
oh damn it just let him rest in peace
but why would someone Nightwing
whoa my man have a face full of fear
oh here we go no
faded Master Nicholas
I'd want you to play
he looks cool yeah the moonlight's red
have you smelled yourself lately
yeah you smell like dank burlap crane
no he'll kill cannot fail
sure you can ass dead ass oh ah take
your zydrate oh whoa sure remote
[Music]
it's cool I like that
damn it
I wouldn't want to make it too easy [Music] oh
the claw it moves when I saw the name Arthur
Wynn and Thomas Elliott's files I knew
he was more than a bit player okay I'll
bite who's Arthur it was the name you used when
visiting Dr Thomas Elliot for your brain tumor
oh I refuse to let that be the end
of Me no no I found another way
or a Lazarus Pit oh yeah in that
moment I saw it who is the Batman
oh [Music] I needed a new persona my true identity
had to be kept Hush Hush I convinced cajoled and
compelled the others to play their part and do my
bidding damn riddled me this Commissioner Gordon
where'd my scar go is Batman oh Jesus [Music]
oh Clayface finally I'm free
cool dinner and a show hey I love
that Joker's just in gen pop like
yep what's the worst that could
happen is hammer on everybody
you're seeing another villain already
thought we had something special
how many others were there no don't tell
me I love jealous lover Joker so much
it's not doing much Gordon oh
now you're just waiting on my parade bat hose oh
anyone got a mint you see I went to the graveyard
to catch a bat but was off by a letter toodles
Batman will come alone he'll compile a
list of every Factory and Warehouse within
the 10 mile radius of which there
are 62. he will not watch the road
check the names of the 14 places to find
that only one is an anagram for Arthur Nguyen
riddle me this the less of me you have
the more I am worth it's time it's time
friend ew I'm going to kill you you're not going
anywhere except down yeah going down [Music]
evil dies tonight what's a bat to do [Music]
the briefest of reprieves I assure you yikes
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
Can you feel it Bruce Can
you feel it all slipping away
can you feel your extreme vacation evaporating
yeah always did what do you think of me now that
you're the same insecure c-lister you were before
you went into the Lazarus Pit you tell riddles
a fifth grader could solve and you call yourself
The Riddler geez best of Ivy Joker and Bane once
they find out hush was the Riddler they'll hunt
you down like a dog they're all going to laugh at
you the effects of the pit don't last forever I'm
betting even now you can feel it all that strength
ingenious slipping away just when you need it most
riddle me this who's His Own Worst Enemy
hahaha
oh
I have you now
nick of time oh
it's got to be so freaking hot in
here they're all wearing leather
yes they're just gonna pull out that's
a big jacket this is like all the sweat
that was gushy yeah
remember now let's beat the
crap out of this [__] yes
that's the cat in the ass hole
[Music]
damn yep
go you're Batman you can't let me die
ugh screw this [__] [Music] they really
the religious Berks of Riddler there
damn I was I was oh not expecting that
you have to repeat that he killed your friend
tried to murder Nightwing how he almost killed me
and you're sorry he's dead if someone can be saved
try seems like he only got worse
you and your God code and you'll
die because of it you know this right will
that make it all better oh without a code
I can't believe I let myself get
caught up in this again oh oh no
no I changed I would have changed more a lot
more for you for us I love you but you won't
or can't oh oh maybe someday but not today
it is not this day goodbye Bruce okay
Bruce the bad guy how could you Coy I
mean bat in the cat gotta break your heart
I should have known let's just rewind 20 minutes
and then they were so happy I love the the moral
quandary of like yeah Catwoman killed the
guy Batman's still wrong like it's like
that that's such a beautiful summation of so
many moving Parts oh yeah absolutely foreign
the Batman the Batman
the hush Batman hush well koibert what
did you think how did this stack up
so uh I love the Batman hush comic and I
remember it differently okay but I read it
it was actually wow I just realized I love
Jim Lee's Art so much Batman hush was when
I first started subscribing monthly to DC
books oh wow so like I was reading DC but
I wasn't like uh uh like collect stack of so I
I remember I bought uh Batman hush and Superman
oh I think it's called like of tomorrow and it's
basically Jim Lee on Superman and I remember
that's what got me to like start physically
collecting DC was this and and Superman Jim
Lee wow uh but that's when I was reading it so 15
years ago sure uh maybe 20. good um so I am maybe
misremembering and maybe this is a spoiler but
um oh okay uh I thought that hush wasn't Riddler
I thought hush was Thomas Elliott that's what I
thought okay I thought that that's what they were
trying to do yeah I think he is in the comic book
and I was very confused when it was Riddler okay
because all right I remember very distinctly
Thomas Elliott being hush sure okay and now
I'm thinking it'd be kind of cool if the Batman
has hush come in the third movie and they we all
think it's Thomas Elliot then it's Paul Daniels
back oh my God like they have the hush money they
have all the like terminology they have the the
someone from his Pad like they could make hush
so this was fun because I kept being
like Greg warned me it was different
and I also remember the hush comic being
more of like a um Batman goes through the
um kind of like goes through his rogue's Gallery
trying to figure out who she is it feels much more
like I've got to fight the villain of the week
but they're all his big villains so it was this
really cool Pace where it was like him beating
up and taking apart his villains to solve this
mystery so this didn't quite feel like that but
it had them all it was just very different tone
I don't remember there being much bat family and
I definitely don't remember the Superman element
being that major of it but yeah what'd you think
yeah I mean this was fun it was yeah it's it's it
was that like summed up in like that quick Montage
where it's like oh they took out Penguins I feel
like he has to freeze and then they and it's just
three panels or whatever whereas in the comics
like each each issue felt like a different villain
but there were some moments that actually didn't
quite translate to animation for me like the um
like the Joker with the bang gun is like the the
last still of a comic book and they like paused on
it for a sec and like they did the thing they did
I think a little better in Dark Knight Returns
where they would like there's an iconic image
um it's just like Jim Lee's Art is so
specific I feel like it just doesn't
quite land in motion here sure that makes
sense I I get where you're coming from
I was nice to see because it made me go like
oh that's how the book ended like I still got
it still sparked Joy condo would say her ex joy so
you will not be discarding I will not be discarded
uh this was like a solid four star out of five
for me this was like you know in the upper half
um but it wasn't it wasn't uh you know it's not
top five but it's up there okay yeah that makes
sense what'd you think I liked it yeah I mean
I I would be very curious to go back and finish
reading the the book because now now I'm just
sitting here going tonight did I finish reading
this book and because they're also there are
other stories that have twists where somebody
close to Batman who doesn't seem like a regular
villain becomes I think like the Phantasm kind of
has that right yeah or like you know it's you're
thinking like oh who is this new villain and who
maybe among the Rogues could be involved but
then in somebody else that's right maybe I'm
just thinking about that but the fact that we're
both misremembering it is interesting because I
really think it was him well because I guess the
thing was when I was watching this I kept feeling
like that was what they were trying to set up like
that was like uh and it was much more about like
him being bad to the people close to him which
made it Thomas like the hush you know from his
past and all that stuff it's yeah there's like
resentment right yeah yeah because that's what
I remember these names are funny you paused
on Tara Strong is not uh Harley here she's
reporter and commissioner Gordon's played by
a guy with all the Wayne's names Bruce Thomas
Bruce Thomas there you go and uh hey everyone
Peyton List was Batgirl and Poison Ivy yeah
yeah that's crazy she's uh Tori yeah yeah yeah
that's cool um no I enjoyed this quite a bit I
mean I like The Vibes uh and and now I'm really
curious to go back and look at the comic because
so much of what I liked about this was like the
bad family stuff and the Batman and cats like is
the bat in the cat stuff is prominent that's
that's in there because like the way Jim Lee
and and the way Jim Lee's composition works
it's so like romantic between the two of them
and then I do remember like years later obviously
they're now together or now they're not again but
for years they were together and I remember this
being like a big like oh my God Batman Revealed
yeah no I love that stuff and like you know
we've been sitting here talking about romance
and passion in these yeah all kinds of movies and
uh and you know we had we had like stuff like that
in the death of Superman certainly with Lois Lane
um but yeah to come here and to really have like
a full-on you know love story of Blossom between
them and see the ways they've changed and yeah
see the interplay between Selena and Bruce and Cat
uh Catwoman and Batman and uh the merging of the
two ideas for both of these people like I really
enjoyed and and kind of got attached to that stuff
so by the end you know when she's yeah going
her separate way like it was such a tragic end
it to you know just like the most Batman yeah
conundrum ever yeah which someone died that's
his code yeah and like you know certainly he
would have every reason to want to kill Riddler
in this moment and especially he like freaking
dug up Thomas Elliott like oh yeah I think so
yeah it's like it's real messed up but uh yeah
like overall I would say yeah it's not like my
top favorite but I definitely enjoyed the ride
and I think it definitely gave me something in
that romance that I really have been you know just
like looking forward to it's such a big party so
many stories yeah we keep talking about it and I
feel like the DC animateds do romance better than
any of the superhero live action we get lately
certainly except Deadpool of course well because
because yeah because I feel like a lot of the
time there isn't as much investment just it's just
not as the the live-action romances don't feel as
invested in really spending time on romance which
yeah granted is not what everybody wants but uh I
don't know I always enjoy partly because yeah and
we're at a point now where I'm used to like again
we're we're post like uh everything doesn't need
to have a love story and now we've really done
that for a long time where it's like yeah there's
not really much love going on and so now I'm like
bring it back like I'd like Joy back bring back
joy and love but yeah I like to I liked having
poison ivy be prominent in here I like Bane and
stuff like that um but you know poison ivy not
like Belle yeah now it's okay who's yeah who is
this painless yeah I just read it off too I should
listen more no my brain forgot in the moment that
I was not just thinking Karate Kid yeah you know
and we got Lady Shiva for like two seconds yep
which I wonder if that'll come back in a I imagine
that continues on because there's what three more
in this DC something like that or whatever
yeah like that uh yeah I definitely enjoyed
it the voice provinces were great scarecrow was
really cool looking just like yeah scarecrow a
lot the Moonlight was cool uh Joker I enjoyed
the different take of um it was you know a lot
of like highlight reel stuff like Joker having
love towards Batman and like the jealousy and
yeah getting to see like we got the greatest hits
villains which is what I remembered from hush
in a different way and I enjoyed it okay yeah
yeah well and I do appreciate that whole bit with
the joker of like you know if Batman's beating him
senseless and he's like I I would normally I would
be all about this but I want it to be something
I am actually responsible for and if there's one
character yeah I absolutely believe that from it
is Joker 100 and that's another thing that did
really well was like each of the characters though
with brief time did feel like an issue of comic
book where they got their time to shine yeah this
still felt you know pretty substantial and there
still felt like there was a lot going on and it
felt like a movie like there were moments where I
was like oh they're like giving it time to breathe
here they're going over here even though it's an
hour and 20 minutes that was definitely like build
up of character relationships yeah yeah absolutely
this this is one of those ones that leaves me
with a unique feeling because I'm sitting here
going like I like this a lot there's a lot I even
loved about this it does feel like spiritually
there's like something off that hasn't yeah like
100 clicked into place or isn't like a full-on
representation so yeah now I'm sitting here going
like did I read more yeah because if you know that
much like that's definitely a pretty pretty deep
into a book because yeah again I don't know if it
was just you know them doing a good job misleading
me here being like I don't know man something
better the whole thing once and you're like
there's a splinter in my mind yes yeah yeah I feel
like this right now the whole audience is like
and I mean the twist with the Riddler I think is
an interesting take because yeah it's like you're
has anybody that must have happened in other ways
in other comics where they like take a classic
character of some kind and then recontext yeah
and like Riddler's leveled up since and I think he
was c-list then I just don't remember that now I I
kind of glad I didn't reread house right before
this because this gets to be like a Crux and I
want to reread hush I actually have like an Elsa
I have hush art on my wall like I love hush but I
wanted to reread it because the fact that I don't
remember the ending well enough to be definitive
about it is it's been 20 years or whatever yeah
which is crazy like yeah I think I think they
did a good job adapting it and if they changed it
great if they didn't change it great but I think
they did a good job like making the mystery work
and there is something that feels just a little
off but overall like I really enjoyed it um love
the continuation of the the rain Wilson Lex Luthor
just like even for that line and it makes me
really excited to see whatever we have next
in this world that's approaching its end because
yeah this is 2019. yeah yeah we're catching up to
the present we need more double dates yeah dude
you gotta read that it's it's Tom King uh who I
talk about a lot and it's two issues and it is
just so charming and delightful and wonderful
it's the two of them and I love it dearly oh it's
called double date it's so good well then I will
be picking that up the second we cut the camera
yeah get them Comics uh little mini Coy's comic
Corners right as plug Comics during the mid uh
animated episode but yeah I feel like there's not
as much to say on this one yeah anyway it's like
it's just straightforward it is what it is yeah
and you're like this is an iconic run and so yeah
you expect this to be like a big punctuation movie
where really it it more like you know looking
at this DC AMU Journey it feels like yes certain
installments you know they're all movies they all
stand on their own but some feel like you know
culminative punctuated events and others feel like
okay we're back in the you know sort of main we're
just kind of back in the episodics of the timeline
right or something like that so like and maybe it
was the speed of going through everyone but like
having a greatest hits villain movie be an hour
and 20 though it worked as a movie maybe that's
why it feels like well that's what it was like it
just doesn't have yeah can't really go further
than that yeah because you know it's the most
substantial stuff is the Bruce and Selena batting
the cat stuff yeah you get a little bit Gordon you
get a little bit of your other you know you get
some Nightwing and some Alfred and then yeah the
rest of the villains stuff is mostly like you know
they get their moment Bane Joker Harley yeah and
then uh yeah you get a couple other little clay
clay face but yeah it's like it's yeah it's not as
jam-packed with stuff yeah and because there's so
much it can't go deeper than that really yeah uh
well that I believe is gonna do it for Batman hush
which I enjoyed uh in my top third not my top five
uh very excited I think this is our 21st one of
these I think we just hit 21 DC animateds we have
watched so I think we're approaching halfway of
all of them and I know we're approaching the end
of this shared universe that's exciting so we're
going to keep cruising along leave a comment let
us know which one you're excited to see us watch
next let us know which uh of these you've enjoyed
the most and also if you were angry that we didn't
remember who hush was I'm excited to join you in
knowing by reading the comic again because I love
this comic so it's gonna be a ton of comments like
it's obviously but uh very excited to dive back
in uh thank you for watching as always thank you
to our patrons for being patrons and share this so
we can keep making these I want to keep watching I
want to finish off the 40 or whatever there are
so we got to make sure people get to click and
of here let us give a very
special shout out to patreon
yes Anisa I gotta go back into the archives from
last month but if we happen to miss you I am sorry
I take personal responsibility in these so you
are one of our longest running you're one of our
best friends you are the Thomas uh what's his name
I keep want to call him Thomas Edison but that's
Thomas you're the lady Thomas Elliott of this
channel you were a remarkable person you stand
by us you're steadfast even though we're always
out here you know just like batting around and and
you know we never got time to just pal around but
you know what we have paddled around once or twice
and I'm glad you're still alive and we could do
so again one day all you can come next time yeah
me and Greg have gone to hang out with Denise
so she's a class act so next time you can join
we can have a whole big project family party yeah
the the pizza places were open for the pandemic
and I had that big like perky Merc thing we
all got pizza yeah that was great I missed
pizza parties dude quirky Mark pizza party pizza
party you're invited you're an honorary invited
love you Nisa stay well and uh and hey you might
get two shout outs this month just to make up for
it so uh you know you feel feel blessed with
the outpouring of Love June extra love acts as
absolutely Pizza I do too stay pledge we're gonna
get some pizza yeah we're gonna get some pizza
[Music]